there are two sort of competing
proposals right now for how to use some
government money this is like a general
topic how should money be spent by the
government money that comes in via tax
revenue there's one proposal to repeal
the estate tax which would be just a
huge windfall for the richest Americans
there is another proposal to give back
pay to the hundreds of thousands of
federal contractors who lost pay during
the recent government shutdown and
they're waiting around hoping to get
that money for the work that they did
while Donald Trump had the government
shutdown where do Republicans come down
on this you might not be surprised to
hear that Republicans want to repeal the
estate tax but not at least yet give
back pay to those contractors affected
by their president's government shutdown
we have two Democrats one in the house
one in the Senate who proposed a bill to
pay the contractors what they are owed
the law doesn't require that they be
paid which is an interesting thing so
the right thing to do if you believe
that they've earned that money and they
need to be paid is you do it through
legislation you say hey this money which
we've already allocated it's not new
money we need to find we were planning
on paying the contractors this money all
along we didn't because we were shut
down we're just going to pass a bill to
get them the money that would affect
hundreds of thousands or possibly
millions of contractors according to the
Washington Post a lot of people that
bill has 20 co-sponsors in the Senate
all are Democrats not a single
Republican as of this morning was behind
the bill as co-sponsors to give the
money to the federal contractors that
they are owed for the work they did
during Donny boys shot down now is it
actually because Republicans don't want
to pay the money is it because
Republicans don't care about paying the
contractors not necessarily I'm guessing
that there are Republicans who are
saying oh I'm not co-sponsoring that
bill merely because they don't want more
attention on the
that the shutdown was a disaster and
they figure keep it out of the news by
not putting my name as a co-sponsor on
this bill but Republicans do have other
ideas about what to do with government
money Mitch McConnell and two other
Republican senators sponsored a bill
which would fully repeal the estate tax
that rich individuals and families pay
on money that's inherited now for all of
you thinking hey we should do that we
should make it so that people aren't
penalized for dying with money we
already did let me remind you that back
in 2017 the loss started in 2017 where
individuals could leave 5.45 million
dollars in their estates tax-free
everything above five point four five
million then there was an estate tax in
2017 Republicans already changed the law
doubling that so that an individual
could leave 11 million tax exempt a
couple could leave 22 million tax exempt
so when you realize that the law already
applies the estate tax already applies
only to individuals leaving more than
eleven million dollars or couples
leaving more than 22 million dollars you
realize that this is a bill that would
impact 1,700 families
okay seventeen hundred families versus
hundreds of thousands or millions of
federal contractors and it's not just
number seventeen hundred already
extraordinarily rich families who will
be able to leave 11 to 22 million
tax-free already versus middle class and
lower middle class federal contractors
who depend on this money who are in
great part part of that portion of the
American population that is living
paycheck to paycheck and remember the
money for the contractors has already
been allocated it's already part of the
budget we're simply saying pay it to the
contractors it doesn't change the budget
repealing the estate tax actually does
reduce government revenue government
revenue that would have
come in under the current law but that
we would no longer get and hasn't been
budgeted and thus would increase the
deficit something that Republicans claim
they don't want this has gone beyond Pat
simply economics into immorality and
kleptocracy by the minority for the
minority that fills their pockets yes
speaking just on the back pay for a
second I thought it was just Trump who
tried to avoid paying people who worked
for him it turns out it's a good portion
of the Republican Party and also I would
go a step further I don't think that the
federal contractors are just owed back
pay I think they're owed like three or
four percent interest on top of that if
you're late on your taxes
you have to pay interest on it you'll
get penalized you end up having to pay
more than you initially owed I think I
think we also owe those federal
contractors not only for the time that
they've missed but also a little
something extra yeah that's something
that's that's being discussed which is
the idea that if you ended up having to
I don't know take a loan out in order to
make your mortgage payment or pay rent
or buy groceries or whatever as the
shutdown was going on as a result of
Donald Trump's temper tantrum shouldn't
you be compensated for that if you are
paying interest on a loan because of the
shutdown shouldn't you have that made up
to you and I think that that ship that
ship hasn't it's not that that ship has
sailed
that ship doesn't exist that ship hasn't
been built that ship is just an idea
not even in a boat yard yet to take the
the ship analogy to its full conclusion
it's the Gilded Age kleptocracy swamp I
don't know what to call it but we need
to end it in 2020 today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blink Asst it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n